Hi, Dr. Connors. Does it matter where I put the bulb under the cover? I have breast cancer.
Also, I do the right every night, but I only get to do the full time on the weekends. I normally
get seven hours of my programs. That's okay. Yes, that's okay. You're getting, you know, I put the
program in and, you know, I mix up the frequencies through every night, so you're not missing anything.
If you were to say, if you called and said, hey, I'm only sleep four hours, okay, well, that's a problem.
But if you're getting seven of the eight to half night hours, you're doing fine.
Where do you put the bulb? You just as close to you as you feel comfortable. That's, you just put
it as close to you as you feel comfortable, even if there's clothing or something in between you.
Also, I wanted to do that cataract program, and I called to rife to get a stand, but they said there was
not one for the model of rife I have. So, I think they meant there's not a stand for the bulb you have.
There's not a stand for the hammer bulb. There's only a stand for the QX2 or the double, double,
double, double, double live. You have some suggestions where I could place the bulb, so that is one foot away from
my eyes for an hour or 15 minutes. Yeah, you could just, you could put it on the back of your neck.
So, you, doesn't have to be, you don't have to be sh solution to your eyes. I wouldn't recommend that,
but yeah, you can put it under your neck. You put it on the back of your neck. It's going through your head.
You know, you know, you don't want to want to put it be your feet because it's too far away from your eyes.
So you could, if you sit in a lazy boy chair or something, you could put it underneath your deck,
and you could lay there, like that. That'd be a good thing or put it on top of your head if you want.